if you haven't seen season seven
it's it starts with him on his knees
because that's how the season
six ended with him on his knees
how much punishment should we put our
main character through
well i i think that
somebody described it best when they
said
what you do to make someone what a story
is is
people chasing a character up a tree and
throwing rocks at them while they're
trying to climb down
that's ultimately what a story is right
and so i think that you should put them
through as much punishment
as they can
weather
and still
realistically want to pursue their goal
and still realistically understand the
stakes you know
one of my favorite shows is the walking
dead right
and there was a period in episode oh in
season
seven was it seven or eight
may have been season seven
and people kind of stopped watching
it went like this and mainly it was due
to
how much punishment they put the main
character through
he
had so much punishment heaped upon him
that his only goal
was not to receive more punishment
that his people would receive no more
punishment
and this was from a character who had
been a a world beater for
six seasons
you know and all of a sudden we're
watching him not only be beaten but to
just be beaten to a point where the
fight is beaten out of them
and i think people jumped off because
that was the point that the punishment
went too far
that was the point where audience was
like okay i'm tapping out i can't do it
anymore there was there was i remember
there was an episode where he just stood
there like it was just one locked off
shot of him
and he just cried and the camera went to
a wide shot and he's just completely
alone and he's crying and there's a guy
who
you know
he just watched be killed that was from
his community and the guy turns into a
zombie so it's even worse now he's at a
freaking after he just witnessed this
happen to the guy and he could do
nothing about it he had to turn around
and be the person to you know
right through the brain to put him out
of his misery like i i think
you know i still kept watching of course
because it's one of my favorite shows
but i can understand why people jumped
off because at that point punishment
went too far
so
you know i think it's
it's it has to be enough punishment
where
it does create the wound that we're all
looking for him to heal
but it can't be so much that if it makes
him forget
the goal
the goal was not to res not to receive
more punishment the goal was to keep his
people safe and get rid of all
threats
and now he's not trying to get rid of
the threat he's trying to live with the
threat and he fears the threat
and i think that's too much for
audiences to to deal with we have to
constantly keep this guy moving forward
and working towards his goal while all
the time realizing he could probably
lose
he could probably lose but we'll root
for him if he keeps pursuing his goal
so it was the fact that we saw the fight
beaten out of him not the that not him
being put through the fight
well he there was no fight he was being
punished and punished and punished and
punished
it was it was so have you seen this uh
seasons if you haven't seen season seven
it's it starts with him on his knees
because that's how the season
six ended with him on his knees so it
starts with him on his knees
and watching two of his friends and he
could do nothing about it they're told
if you move
we'll kill everybody but for right now
we're just gonna kill this one guy in
front of you all
and they proceed to beat this guy's head
in with a baseball bat
in front of
all his friends
and another guy can't take it anymore he
gets up and hits the bad guy and the bad
guy says that's gonna cost you
because now i'm gonna beat another guy
head in and he beats another guy's head
in all the while the leader has to watch
this happen and he can do nothing
he starts the season on his knees
watching his friends die and there's
nothing he can do
and then for the rest of that season
he's met with even more punishment and
more punishment and the threat is always
if you don't do what we say and you
don't give us what we want we'll show up
and kill everybody don't forget that and
it's like how many times can you see
that and how many times can you see that
and the good guy
not say
that's it we got to come up with a plan
his only plan is to make sure there's
not more punishment
you can't you can't do that to audiences
they have to see the fight they have to
see the struggle they have to see you
trying to win
not being complacent with being proud
beaten
you know
would you say the more punishment we put
our protagonists through the better the
story is going to be to a certain extent
yes
to a certain extent as long as we don't
put them through too much i think that
we have to see
i mean for my stories i love to
to to show the person show their wound
and then show how they've begin to live
with this wound by accepting it as a
truth even though it's a false truth
and how their world is with that right
now this person may not be down on their
luck or anything but something has
happened and this is told them that this
is the way you live life right and there
has to be something that forces them on
their journey
when they start going on their journey
they can't win every little
battle they gotta lose but they gotta
see that you know what but i can see on
the other side of it if i just keep
going because this these are the stakes
and i can't allow myself to lose
they have to take enough punishment
along the way
where you
you keep believing in them even if they
don't they don't really believe in
themselves
and then it has to get to a point where
it's a soul-crushing defeat like right
when they thought they won it's a
soul-crushing defeat
and you got to watch them pick up the
pieces and you got to fill you got to
that's when you you know circle the
wagons and you know you're bringing
together all the different people that
are going to help you build build the
character back up and put them back on
their their journey because now they
realize this is the worst that it can
get
you know this is the worst that this guy
can do to me but the stakes are still
the stakes i still have to stop this
thing from happening whatever it is
right so they've absorbed all this
punishment and they realize that's the
worst that it can get
so this guy cannot hurt me any more than
this only by them succeeding at their
goal
so now i'm just going to go straight
after them straight away now there's
many different ways of what you can do
to get them to stop the bad guy or the
bad guy succeeds or whatever but
at this point that's when the audience
is behind them they receive enough
punishment where
they have
hopefully
garnered the sympathy of the audience
and the audience is behind them
so that when they lead them into this
final battle the audience is right
behind them right on the horse right
behind him like oh
you know and you're you're watching this
person go in and save the day
now
if you give them too much punishment i
think the audience can bail
because they're just i've seen it happen
they just bailed i don't think you can
watch a person just lose
you know i don't think you can watch him
just lose they have to have some win
somewhere